(Music)
Jennifer Aniston:
We are ripe and ready for this
conversation.
And it's heartbreakingly honest.
It's been one of the most
fulfilling experiences of my
life.
(Music)
Stand-by Eight...
Eight seconds to you.
The show is sharp, and
insightful, and ultimately very
human.
Three...
Two...
Start your move...
Cue her!
Good morning!
(Music)
Our show, The Morning Show, is
really set in the world of
morning television.
Janina Gavankar:
The world of the anchors, and
the news,
and all of the people
that wake you up in the
mornings.
There's just this adrenalized,
very ambitious, and almost
Machiavellian energy.
The anxiety, fear of losing your
position, desire to come out on
top.
This shows me what this world
is.
Mitch and Alex are the darlings
of morning tv. They're
incredibly close friends.
And there's a love between them.
Mitch, that's my on-air partner.
My tv husband.
We know more about each other
than me and my husband, and he
and his wife.
But, it's inevitable that they
have some difficult and rocky
times.
I'm sorry!
Me too!
Mitch, he's so charming and
likable, he doesn't really
realize the power and
it's affect on other people. I
mean he does bad things, and I
think it's disconcerting.
But I love the fact that it's so
grey and complicated.
He's a very flawed human being,
but he's a human being.
You are my best friend, you are
like a part of me.
Me too, honey.
Reese Witherspoon:
Alex Levy has
been at The Morning Show for 17 years,
Reese Witherspoon:
but her entire world has fallen
apart.
Reese Witherspoon:
And she's grasping to get
control of her life again.
I just need to be able to
control the narrative so that I
am not written out of it.
My relevance is at stake here,
everything that I live for is
all in this show,
and she's fighting for her life.
I'm not closing without Carl's
approval.
Well I'm sorry to hear that
because you're not getting it.
(Music)
So, Bradley, what is your story?
I don't fit the mould.
What mould is that?
Any mould, really.
Bradley Jackson comes in and
completely stirs the pot.
She has a tendency to not think
before she speaks.
Well you know how many jobs have
been lost in the last 10 years?
Huh?
I don't know!
Thousands!
So when she gets the opportunity
to be on The Morning Show,
Reese Witherspoon:
she's determined to sort of make
the best of that.
We want to interview you.
The Morning Show?
Your words spoke to America.
(Music)
These characters go on a long
journey together in a very short
period of time.
Mimi Leder:
How they get there is
fascinating.
So you're a diehard reporter.
The truth matters to me.
The truth is what we are all
striving for.
Yeah.
Here's someone younger and who
has tapped into the fearlessness
in her quest for the truth.
Jennifer Aniston:
What Bradley says resonates
within Alex,
but she's also
terrified of it.
These two complicated women in a
complicated work environment,
Kerry Ehrin:
are gonna eventually collide and
it's a world that's often dark.
Kerry Ehrin:
But also, there's definitely a
beating heart in it.
And I think a hope.
You all are so convinced that
you are the rightful owner of
all of the power that it doesn't
even occur to you that someone
else could be in the driver's
seat.
I think it's really powerful and
emotional.
I gave up everything for this
show!
Any chance of having a
normal life!
(Music)
I think it's really about a
reckoning.
Just stay!
Realizing that it's time for
change.
(Music)